let's do one final worked example
together I'm gonna skip a big chunk of
the exercise and go straight to 9a part
1 now picked out this guy you might
better guess why because again you've
got these negative numbers flying around
and they're easy to muck up so I've got
X to the power of negative 2 that's the
thing that I'm integrating so I put in
my square bracket and then I think what
will the primitive function be now if
you think back to when you
differentiated if you had some X to the
power of M the first thing we did was we
brought down the index and then we
reduce the index by 1 so conversely when
you are integrating X to the power of n
we're going to do the exact opposite of
that right so you are going to increase
the power by 1 and then divide should
say increase the index by 1 and then
divide by that new index and in this
case I've written an indefinite integral
so this guy here is going to be the
basis of what I use just be very very
careful with those negative indices
because you know I can tell you right
now don't write this in the most common
error when students have a look at a
question like this is to write this
right it's so very very close right what
have they done they've said all two goes
up into three and then I divide by that
new index it's so close to being right
like it looks real evaluated you've got
some reasonable numbers out and the
problem of course is when you increase
negative two by one you don't get
negative three you get negative one so
this is actually what we should be
writing as the primitive let me write
that in the correct color to indicate
that so this is the primitive we should
have ended up with that goes from 5 up
to 10 now at this point rather than
going straight into my evaluation using
the fundamental theorem my F of 10 take
away f of B I will take the opportunity
to do a teeny bit of cleanup here and
this will often be the case so before I
evaluate I'm gonna say that negative on
the denominator that looks a bit gross
I'm going to put it up the top so
negative 1 up there and X to the power
of negative 1 a negative index is really
about division right so the next the X
to the power of negative 1 can become an
X or the denominator that's a bit tidier
for me to deal with so now I'm ready to
evaluate I'm going to do
the upper bound 10 subtracted from the
lower bound 5 so that gives me negative
1 over 10 I'm gonna take away negative 1
over 5 now I'm gonna just give the same
caution that I gave before be deathly
careful with your negative signs here
you can see for example these brackets
that I put around the negative 1 over 10
they're completely unnecessary like it
doesn't add anything really to have them
there but for me it's such a helpful
mental thing to have them there and then
to mirror them when I do it when I do F
of a this ensures that when I do the
subtraction and the double negatives and
sometimes is triple negatives can be
very very confusing and this will make
sure I get all the signs right so I'm
gonna have the negative 1 over 10 out
the front double negative becomes plus 1
over 5 and if you're thinking again
about your comment denominators that are
1 over 5 is 2 tenths so that's going to
be 1 over 10 there's my answer
ok so what we learned
well this fundamental theorem of
calculus right when it enables us to do
and you'll see this as we go further
into the next few exercises what enables
us to do is to think about the areas
under curves of shapes that are really
weird and wacky so for example let's
just have a look at this one here X to
the power of negative 2 what doesn't
even look like right well if I just
bring whoops
let's bring this guy up from the side
here all right X to the power of
negative 2 and you're welcome to open up
desmos yourself and play along at home
there's X to the power negative 2
where's it gone huh I've done something
funny with my indices let's try it again
yeah there we go all right so there's my
I need to see more of this graph X to
the power of negative 2 it's a weird
looking graph you're like oh my gosh I
hope I am NOT expected to know how to
graph that we're not as part of this
particular question but I'm gonna use
this graph nonetheless to help you
illustrate what's going on what's the
area that corresponds to the value that
we got before
well I'm considering from 5 all the way
over to 10 now if you want to actually
show where that area is what you do is
you say ok well let's shade something I
don't know if you knew that you could
shade regions in desmos here's the way
you would do it you would say from
why up until X to the power of negative
two this is going to shade everything
underneath that graph that we just did
but I actually don't want everything I
only want a particular spot from five to
ten so I'm going to use you've got to go
to your other keyboard here
it's me curly braces I'm gonna go from
five to ten now you can't see that very
clearly here so let me zoom in for you
I'm gonna change the vertical axis while
I'm at it here we go that's much more
useful all right that's looking more
reasonable now this is the area that we
were evaluating now I have no idea of
what formula you could use like that's
they're not part of circles or quadrants
or triangles it's a curvy weird shape
but calculus enables us to find out that
black area nonetheless because of the
fundamental theorem of calculus you're
very perceptive and I admit I did do
this I did slightly pull the fast on you
so let me explain a little more clearly
how did I flip the x on negative one
alright so actually in truth let's let's
unpack this in more detail on its own so
let's just take this guy here and let's
let's get some in your space for it okay
so so this this is a bit of a mess and
what I've done is and I apologize I've
done two things at the same time so
number one the numerator is messy and
number two the denominator is messy and
I tried to clean up both them at the
same time let's do them one at a time
instead so when I have a look at this
fraction right I'll do with the
denominator first it's a bit easier to
change the denominator to be positive
because ordinarily when we write
fractions we like the denominators to be
positive just like we like to nominators
to be rational so if you think back to
like you nine and ten we spent a long
time if you've got a third you would
rationalize the denominator Oh Springs
Mike what happened hold on what's going
on can you see mrs. Lee's oh I see uh I
maximized sorry my fault okay let me
start that again
so here we've got this messy looking
fraction right and I want the top and
bottom to be negative right okay so
let's just let's just deal with that we
worry about SERDES
so to do that I'm going to multiply the
top and the bottom by the same thing so
as I multiply the top of the bottom by
the same thing I actually still have the
same fraction so the easiest way to fix
that is to multiply the top of the
bottom by negative one okay if I do that
just make sure I'm on the right spot in
the chat if I do that the fraction is
still the same but it will get rid of
that negative that you saw on the bottom
right so I'm going to write this as
negative x to the negative one divided
by negative one times negative one
negatives cancel I just get positive one
you're happy with that part yeah let me
give me a give me a thumbs up more if
you've got that part okay fantastic
right so we've dealt with the
denominator now let's deal with the
numerator now in some ways maybe the
easiest thing is to actually pull the
same trick right I'm going to multiply
the top in the bottom by the same thing
so that everything stays the same right
this time to get rid of this negative
index on the top I'm going to multiply
by X to the power of 1 on X to the power
of 1 same thing on the top and the
bottom so I'm not changing the fraction
I'm just going to make it look a little
bit different okay so let's have a think
what happens to the top well I've got X
to the power of negative 1 and then I've
got X to the power of 1 hit pause on
that let's have a look at the bottom
I've got one time exit I did you see it
okay good so on the bottom I'm just
gonna have X and now on the top here
we'll just have a look right when you
multiply numbers indices where the bases
are the same well we just add the
indices right so I'm gonna get negative
x to the power of 0 anything to the
power of 0 though is just 1 so that's
where I get negative 1 over X that's a
bit of a long-winded way to do it so I
kind of was a bit sneaky squeezing all
of that into a single line of working
but I guess and this actually is maybe
another thing to add to mrs. Liza's
point about negative numbers the other
thing that you're going to get over and
over again is your index laws I'm just
going to appear and they're just gonna
be brittle like every question is gonna
be like 5 index questions all packed in
at the same time and it's a bit like I
know I've used this analogy before but
I'm just gonna use it again it's like
when you first learn to drive right when
you first learn to drive you're like oh
my gosh how do I hold the steering wheel
not jerk it so people we like
flying out of their seats and brake and
change the gear and oh my gosh I'm
learning manual because I'm crazy and
now I've got to do the clutch as well
and they feel like all these separate
things in your brain but eventually
maybe you're up to this point already
noé they become the kind of second
nature your brain is actually feeding
them all into things that you're like I
can do these without thinking too hard
about them and therefore focus on the
things that I need to concentrate on so
in this case the indices and the
negatives and the fractions these are
things that go back to you know years 7
8 9 et cetera
right so this is building on all of that
and it's kind of treating that as
assumed knowledge and saying hey you
really need to master that so that you
can focus on the calculus here and what
mrs. Li said before is true and where
students lose their marks is often not
on the calculus at all it's on stuff
they learned in year 7 to 10 or didn't
learn in year 7 to 10